Okay,
here is why more and more young women are rejecting feminism and just,
like, do not wanna be associated with it at all.
I think these younger generations have really,
really good BS detectors.
So on its face,
feminism sounds great, right?
Equality for all and girls supporting girls,
that sounds so beautiful.
But the second you kinda test that out,
you very quickly find that it has just become a total facade.
If I'm putting on makeup for my husband to come home from work,
or if I'm cooking for him,
they get upset.
They don't like that.
Like, whoever the head of PR is for feminism needs to be fired.
They are doing a horrible job
because almost all of their representatives who are outspoken,
they just seem so miserable,
so hateful, so bitter.
It doesn't look fun at all.
Nothing about that sounds appealing.
That's why we're starting to see the, like,
Chad wife stuff on TikTok
is because people are so sick of the other side.
Like, so done with the angry man hating,
like, putting women down.
Look, it's boring,
it's old. We're done with it.
You don't have to like me.
You don't have to like other women on social media.
You can call everybody names and be upset,
but just don't pretend that you support other women, because you don't.
And a lot of people are seeing right through it.